et au delà du manque de personnel
hospitalier le pass sanitaire antique au
lead continue de diviser nouveau
rassemblement aujourd'hui devant le
sénat à l'appel du mouvement des
patriotes on retrouve tout de suite sur
place luc alléger
une cave vous êtes donc devant le palais
du luxembourg le rendez vous était fixé
à 17 heures est ce qu'il ya déjà du
monde autour de vous
[Musique]
oui absolument la manifestation est en
train de se mettre en place les
organisateurs viennent juste de passer
de la musique on entend le sauveur
habituel liberté ces manifestants ils
étaient déjà devant l'assemblée
nationale la semaine dernière ils
étaient venus à plusieurs centaines pour
faire pression sur les députés alors que
le texte passé devant cette chambre il
est passé sans encombre ce n'est pas une
surprise ça pourrait être différent
devant le sénat puisque la majorité ait
l'air n'est pas favorable à donner
autant de liberté au gouvernement
pendant aussi longtemps jusqu'au 31
juillet 2022 comme ils le demandaient
ils veulent qu'il y ait un nouveau vote
avant le 28 février date à laquelle le
parlement doit à rentrer en suspension
jusqu aux prochaines élections qu'on se
manifestant de toute façon il n'est pas
question de diminuer l'impact de ce
texte il faut tout simplement réouvert
le pays je vous propose de les écouter
ni le passé ni terre dans l'objectif
officiel était la baisse
de la contamination et la prévention
d'une pseudo quatrième vague n'a eu
comme simple effet que d'augmenter le
taux de vaccinés parce que sous la
contrainte avec l'obligation vaccinale
et avec les contraintes de pas
sanitaires aujourd'hui donc il est
absolument illégitime que ninon députés
ni nos sénateurs ne vaut pas
prolongation
la loi quand discussion est ni plus ni
moins que la destruction de nos acquis
sociaux et sociétaux c'est une loi
fondamentale la constitution qui est en
train d'être détruite détricoté par nos
parlementaires et aujourd'hui nous
sommes devant le sénat pour mettre les
sénateurs devant leurs responsabilités
ils doivent protéger les intérêts du
peuple ils doivent les protéger en
étudiant la loi et surtout en retoquant
tout ce qui est anti constitutionnelle
hier en audition au sénat olivier
ferrand a défendu la politique sanitaire
du gouvernement selon lui le pass
sanitaires et toutes les mesures annexes
ton permis de limiter de 30 pour cent la
circulation du virus pour lui il n'est
pas question de baisser le bouclier
pendant l'hiver alors que death ou
marion du variant delta suscite des
inquiétudes outre manche les
manifestants contre le passage ita sont
toujours mobilisés ils battent le pavé
depuis 15 samedi depuis les annonces des
manuels macro le 2 juillet d'instaurer
un pass sanitaires la semaine dernière
ils étaient environ 40000 selon le
ministère de l'intérieur 73000 selon le
collectif militant le nombre jaune
toujours mobilisés jusqu'à ce que ces
mesures soient purement et simplement
abandonnée merci le cas légers pour
toutes ces précisions donc devant le
sénat à paris